>>Jeff Garlin: So I'm going to read. Let's
start with chapter one. Why not huh?
[laughter]
And the first line is not a lie its true sometimes
but most of the time it's not true.
And I'm, I, I just feel that I should point
that out it being chapter one and I as I've
being reading that first line is just not
true. So, it's true for this circumstance,
so let's leave it at that. So it is true for
this but in general not true.
God bless my wife she always calms me down.
[laughter]
As I'm looking through the mail this morning
she says: "You're gonna to see something you're
not going to like."
And I say: "Really what?"
She pauses gives me a knowing look.
How's things in Santa Monica? Yeah!
[laughter]
'Cause I'm never going to forget this. Hi.
I'm never going to forget this this is the
weirdest thing ever.
[laughter]
Are there more than two employees? I just
- wait.
[laughter]
>>Julie: Wait, wait we can't hear you.
Oh I can hear you.
>>Julie: We can hear you now.
>>Jeff Garlin: Oh hi oh I can talk to you.
>>Julie: Hi, yes.
>>Jeff Garlin: Can you explain what's going
on here?
[laughter]
Was there, was there a fire alarm of some
sort?
>>voice from audience: We're offended now
'cause we didn't hear it.
>>Jeff Garlin: There's nothing to be offended.
>>Julie: We couldn't get connected.
>>Jeff Garlin: Ok. So -
>>Julie: Now we can.
>>Jeff Garlin: So my question to you is there
a fire alarm of some sort or how do you explain
no one being there?
[laughter]
>>Julie: Well you know what, it actually has
to do with overeating because today we have
a brand new caterer starting in our office
and everybody's up there eating.
[laughter]
So we're the only, and he brought his food,
I, I wanted to see you before I ate so I wouldn't
eat as much.
[laughter]
So, that's how I'd explain it.
>>Jeff Garlin: What, what's your name?
[laughter]
>>Julie: Julie.
>>Jeff Garlin: Julie. So do me a favor, Julie.
Wow. Can, can someone tell me how to get a
hold of her? 'Cause next, this Friday March
26th, I wanna invite you to my show at the
comedy store as my guest.
[applause]
>>Julie: Oh thank you. That would be awesome.
>>Jeff Garlin: You, you, you and a guest maybe
the person who is eating with you.
[laughter]
>>voice from audience: That's Pertick.
>>Jeff Garlin: That's what's his name.
>>voice from audience: He's Pertick.
>>Jeff Garlin: Perteed. Perteed.
>>voice from audience: Pertick.
>>Jeff Garlin: Pertick. Okay, like I'd know
the difference.
>>Pertick: I'm an Indian guy, that's fine.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Pertick, a pleasure, Pertick.
Pertick you can come too. So each of you can
bring someone. I'm not gonna to make you start
dating.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Although I know you and Pertick
have had a, a thing going on in the office.
[laughter]
See here's what I know. Pertick is not all
that interested in me but he knows his getting
some good alone time with you.
[laughter]
So, so can you give me her, her information?
>>voice in audience: [unintellgible]
>>Jeff Garlin: Okay so I'm gonna to get your
information and my assistant will be contacting
you and you guys can come to the show this
Friday. Okay?
>>Julie: Oh, thanks a lot Jeff.
>>Jeff Garlin]: Do what I can. Do you guys
-
[laughter]
>>Jullie: Totally.
>>Jeff Garlin: See I'm telling you Pertick
doesn't give a crap about me.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Who just walked by? Somebody
walked by.
>>voice from audience: I went to the Paley
Panel last week. I just saw you and -
>>Jeff Garlin: Oh you went to the Paley Panel
with everybody from Curb. How about that?
Okay.
>>voice from audience: Yeah
>>Jeff Garlin: Good. Well thank you.
[many people speaking at once]
Pertick, I think. What?
>>Petrick: I want to say just like you I do
have an issue with overeating. So this is
gonna be great, great talk for me.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Okay. Who was that? Who was
that? Who was that? Who are these people?
[laughter]
They're not eating they should be watching.
Alright.
[laughter]
Okay, so I'm going to go back to reading but
I'm getting' you guys set up for my show.
Okay?
>>Julie: You're awesome. Thank you.
>>Pertick: Thank you.
>>Jeff Garlin: I just get the feeling Pertick
that you're not that interested.
[laughter]
Just my gut feeling. I just don't know why
yet.
[laughter]
Alright but for nonetheless I'm a man of my
word. Alright I'm gonna to read a couple of
things here. So, alright here we go.
God bless my wife she always calms me down.
As I'm looking through our mail this morning
she says: "You're going to see something you're
not gonna to like."
And I say: "Really what?"
She pauses gives me a knowing look and says:
"Just use it in your comedy."
I start thumbing through the mail. I've received
a catalog from the good people at Living XL.
It's a catalog for fat people who wanna stay
fat and enjoy themselves.
[laughter]
The message is basically: don't lose weight,
no no no. All the problems that you normally
have with being fat we've got a solution.
How in the, how do they know to send me a
catalog? Do they have a list of fat celebrities?
I open it up. The first product on offer is
a three-wheeled bike with a 500 pound capacity.
[laughter]
As I look at this contraption, I'm wondering
how many 500 pound people are sitting around
and thinking, "I so wanna go biking. I just
don't have the opportunity.
[laughter]
I weigh 450. If only there was a bike that
could hold my weight. Then I'd have no excuse."
[laughter]
[pause]
The pages don't turn so easy. Next up fat
ponchos. Because we know the regular poncho
is so slimming.
[laughter]
Has anyone ever put on a poncho and said:
"This is not freeing enough."
[laughter]
I only, I guess the only way this thought
would cross your mind is if you're a really
fat woman and you're wearing a mumu underneath
your oversized poncho.
[laughter]
Now how about one of those chairs you bring
to a kids soccer game except this one's got
an 800 pound capacity. How many 800 pounders
do you see out in society?
[laughter]
It must be for a 400 pounder who's got a 400
pound girlfriend who wants to sit on his lap.
[laughter]
Okay, okay, okay here's a hammock with a 600
pound capacity. Now I don't care what you
weigh getting on and off a hammock is quite
difficult.
[laughter]
I don't care if you weigh 150 hammock mobility
is hard for everyone. So you're 600 pounds.
The odds of you getting on that hammock are
so slight.
[laughter]
You're going to be on the ground; you're 600
pounds. Once you do get on you're never getting
off.
[laughter]
Let's see here, here's one with a great name,
it's called the Pride XL Mobility Chair.
I read the description and learn that when
you press a button on the chair instead having
to get up the chair lifts you up. And yet
they call it the pride mobility chair. I think
one of the first things about being a proud
person is that you can stand up on your own.
[laughter]
I'm not talking about someone in a wheelchair
or someone who was in an accident. I'm talking
about when you really don't have a reason
for not being able to stand up for yourself.
[laughter]
They should call it the embarrassment mobility
chair.
[laughter]
Next up is something you've probably seen
in commercials. And to me this is so horrible
and wrong. It's the Living XL wearable sleeves
blanket. Now how many times have you covered
yourself in a blanket and then thought I can't
get up, I can't maneuver if only I had sleeves.
[laughter]
It's only a matter of time before you see
someone wearing this thing at the grocery
store, to keep warm, while perusing the frozen
foods aisle.
They've got toilets alright. Here's one a
toilet seat called the Big John Toilet Seat.
And if you think I'm making this up, I'm not;
1200 pound capacity. Can a 1200 pound person
get up and go to the bathroom? Let alone sit
down and read. Twelve hundred pounds. Who's
taking a shit in that house?
[laughter]
It's described as durable and convenient.
I understand the need for durability on this
one. But what makes it more convenient than
other toilet seats? Oh, right it must be for
the 400 pound man with the 400 pound girlfriend
who wants to sit on his lap while he goes
number two or in this case, number five.
[laughter]
Here's another bottomed out contraption. The
pistol grip no bend toe nail clippers. Not
being able to reach your toes. That's like,
it's like this long and you can do it like
that.
[laughter]
Not being able to reach your toes because
of the size of your belly. I'm sorry but that's
a low point.
Maybe it's not the low point. You could be
wearing a blanket and clipping your toenails
while taking a dump on the big john.
[laughter]
It's a low point just the same.
But here's the moment that might be the real
bottom for me. I turn the page and look at
the model who's displaying the cabin comfort
inflatable pillow, and who do you think he
looks like? That's right he looks like me.
When you're going through a fat catalog and
making fun of it and you get to the last page
and the model is your twin; that's your low
point. It was embarrassing enough just being
sent a copy in the mail but the fact that
I look like a model in Living XL renders me
speechless.
I just don't know what to say. He looks just
like me. Well I've always wanted to look like
a model but not one from a Living XL catalog.
So, this is my bottom. Done. I'm not messing
around anymore. I'm like the captain in Wall-E.
If not now then when? You will see a weight
loss festival like you've never imagined.
So this is the top of chapter one. I maybe
fail 40 or 50 more times. I think that I'm
going to do it but I don't. I mean eventually
I do, but boy that the thing I'm most proud
of the book is it's a book of failure.
[laughter]
And failure is funny, and its honest you know.
It's about me, just so you know overall, trying
to go green and trying to lose weight. Mostly
during the production of this past seasons
of Curb Your Enthusiasm.
By the way, the reason just so you know, that
I didn't want you guys up on the screen, I
felt a change in the room when you started
seeing yourself. And one of the worst things
in the world is, is when you're watching yourself
while someone's trying to do something comedic.
And you'll be way too self-conscious if you
see, like are they laughing, do they think
it's funny.
So a big blue screen is fantastic.
[laughter]
This is teaching you about comedy. I want
you to leave here knowing more about comedy.
[laughter]
Also, when you're on stage never have children
or animals up there with ya. No one will pay
attention to you.
[laughter]
Okay. It's the truth. People love kids and
love animals. That's it. Done.
[laughter]
Let's see here. So I'm going to now read.
I think its page 67. Hold on. No that's not
what I wanna read. I wanna read back here.
Okay. I'm gonna to read to you now. As I look
for it, I'll tell you.
I decided to, to, to try and go green and
Ed Begley tries help, he helps me a lot. He's
pretty brilliant at it. If you think about
it his fifth choice is driving a Prius. Think
about that. Fifth choice, with reservations.
First choice is walking, then bicycle, then
bus, then his electric car, and then if he
has to he feels horrible about it he'll drive
his wife's Prius. So he's in another land
from you and me.
So let me find his here. Nope. It's chapter
15. That's right I remember now.
What chapter is this?
So anyhow I'm gonna to tell you about riding
the bus. And know that in Los Angeles, unlike
San Francisco or New York or Chicago, nobody
takes the bus. Nobody. I mean I shouldn't
say nobody; plenty of people do, but the people
that take the bus cannot afford cars.
That's pretty - maybe five people take it
for green reasons. And then, but mostly it's
people that really don't have the money for
a car.
I know that because it's really, it's out
of the way. Like, well you'll hear as I read,
read about it.
I'm not brave by taking the bus but it's extraordinarily
inconvenient; and stupid on some levels. Well
you'll hear.
Okay.
[laughter]
We are filming a scene at Larry David's house
in Brentwood, where Larry offers to put his
cousin and his daughter through college.
Today is the day I finally start my month
long only taking the bus festival. I have
to leave at 7:20 am to make a 9:00 am call
time. Nonetheless, I left my house this morning
so crazy excited.
I don't like walking unless I have a destination.
So I'm happy to be bouncing to the bus.
My wife was so proud of me as I walked out
the door and she also thought I was an idiot.
I think that she is both proud and thinks
I'm an idiot every day but today the dichotomy
is heightened.
[laughter]
She actually offered me a ride to the bus
stop. Very nice of her but I don't think she's
quite getting it.
[laughter]
As I'm walking down the hill, a steep hill,
I pass a neighbor walking his dog and I say
to him I'm taking the bus today. As if I'm
an eight year old on his first day of school.
[laughter]
Oh good for you. That's great. That's great.
Now it's about a mile walk from my house to
the bus stop. About midway there's a busy
street with no sidewalk. So there's a level
of danger, which today only adds to the excitement.
I pass my old house which isn't far from where
I live now.
I used to live down the block from this Jewish
guy who actually built his own fence. I remember
being so impressed that a Jew would build
a fence.
[laughter]
I would seeing him working on it and think,
"What are you doing?" Not only did he physically
not look like the type of a guy to build a
fence, but it seemed so out of character.
I am not baron von religious but I follow
the credo of Jews throughout history. Which
is: "I have an idea to build a fence; hey
I'll pay somebody to build my fence.
[laughter]
Whatever the price, I'll be happy to pay it.
I'll pay them and I'll probably serve them
lunch."
But this Jew actually built his own fence.
As I passed by it, on my way to the bus stop,
I notice that flowers and vines have grown
all over it, and it occurs to me that I have
driven by that fence many times in the years
since I've lived here and never once noticed
the flowering vines.
Just as healthy eating retained, retrained
my taste buds to appreciate a low sodium diet.
Maybe this walking business will teach me
to appreciate nature without Blue Ray.
[laughter]
When I get to the bus stop.
Thank you.
[laughter]
When I get to the, I thought that was a good
line.
When I get to the bus stop there's about 40
people waiting at 7:45 in the morning. I take
out my iPhone to call my wife and tell her
that I made it.
By the way, at this point, not many people
had iPhones. That's why I was conscience about
taking it out; I didn't want to show off.
[laughter]
Should I call it a Google phone just for the
rest of the story?
[laughter]
She was a bit nervous because the part of
the walk where there is no sidewalk and the
trucks, trucks come flying by.
Remember that I considered getting a bicycle
to ride to the bus after Ed told me that you
could put your bike on the front. But my family
voted that I'm not allowed to ride a bike
to the bus; or for that matter anywhere in
this city. They think I'll hurt myself.
[laughter]
So I call my wife and while I'm talkin' to
her I realize that nobody around me has an
iPhone. In fact, there is not one person at
the bus stop who wouldn't be driving if they
had a car. I'm certainly the only idiot doing
if for my carbon footprint, and I'm worry,
and I worry that I'm calling attention to
myself by talking on my iPhone, so I end the
call quickly and put it away.
If I'm going to be taking the bus with these
people for the next month I don't want them
thinking that the new guy with an iPhone is
a douche bag.
[laughter]
At this point the bus pulls up and all these
people get on. I'm talking about every single
one of them. Which makes me nervous because
I don't think it's the right number bus for
me.
As a matter of pride I'm not going to ask
anyone. I wanna do it myself.
As the doors close, I'm standin' there alone
anxiously wondering if I missed my bus, when
another one with the right number pulls up.
I get on and show my pass. This is all very
exciting.
[laughter]
Now, I had thought that taking the bus would
be relaxing; that I would read or perhaps
pull out my notebook; jot down some notes.
But I have a long ride until I have to change
busses; plenty of times, plenty of time to
relax.
Turns out it is packed; hugely packed. There's
no place to sit. I stand for about 10 minutes
until someone gets off right behind me and
I can finally sit down. But the only available
seat is a priority seat for someone who is
older, handicapped or pregnant.
So from that moment on I'm sitting there stressed
thinking if somebody old or pregnant or wheelchair
bound gets on I'm screwed.
[laughter]
I peer out the window as we approach each
stop praying that everyone waiting is young,
male and healthy.
[laughter]
Meanwhile, I'm sitting across from a woman
who looks like an angry librarian and she's
staring at me with the greatest distain. I
wonder if she's thinking: "Why are you here;
you have a car. Why are you on the bus? What
are you trying to prove? I have to be here;
what's your excuse?"
She keeps clearing her throat and I'm convinced
that she waiting for me to take the hint and
relinquish my priority seat. But I'm terrified
of having to stand again. I have a horrible
back and the sure way to aggravate it is to
stand for long periods of time.
I don't dare speak nor do I feel I can do
anything else. I don't know why I am feeling
so intimidated. But for whatever reason I'm
afraid to do anything.
It's a little hot on the bus. But I'm afraid
to take off my jacket. I don't want to pull
out my iPhone and listen to songs. I just
wanna remain as innocuous as possible.
I'm afraid to fall asleep. There's no music,
no talking. The bus is completely silent.
You can hear everyone breathing.
Toward the end of the ride a woman gets on.
Under normal circumstances I would get up
for a woman, but not today.
[laughter]
At least she's young, probably in her 30's.
And after all the anticipation it's an awkward
long bus ride. I'm waiting in Westwood for
my second bus.
Westwood, you hear that Santa Monica? Nearby.
[laughter]
Is someone new there? Hold on one second.
Who else? Hi.
>>female voice in audience: Hi
>>male voice in audience: Hi
>>Jeff Garlin: Who are you guys?
>>female voice in audience: There's four of
us now.
>>Jeff Garline: Who are you guys?
[pause]
Who are you?
>>male voice in audience: Introduce yourselves.
>>male voice in audience: Oh, I'm Chris.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Hi Chris.
>>female voice in audience: I'm Joan.
>>Jeff Garlin: You're Jill or June?
>>female voice in audience: Joan. [laughs]
>>Jeff Garlin: Joan, Joan?
>>Joan: Yeah, that's
>>Jeff Garlin: Okay.
>>Joan: Yep.
>>Jeff Garlin: Were you guys eating is that
why you were late?
[laughter]
>>male voice in audience: Yeah, a new caterer.
>>Jeff Garlin: I heard. Very exciting. Very
exciting.
I can understand -
>>male voice in audience: It really is.
>>Jeff Garlin: I can understand. So there's
a lot of eating disorder stuff going on at
Google in Santa Monica; where food takes a
priority of a mentally talented handsome man.
[laughter]
>>male voice in audience: Sorry
>>female voice in audience: We might need
you to come visit -
>>Jeff Garlin: Alright let me finish the bus
story.
>>female voice in audience: and mentor.
>>Jeff Garlin: Are you enjoying the bus story
so far?
>>male voice in audience: Yes
>>female voice in audience: Very much.
>>Jeff Garlin: Good.
>>male voice in audience: We've never been
on the bus.
>>female voice in audience: I have. [laughs]
>>Jeff Garlin: By the way back me on this;
it's pretty crazy where we live to be on the
bus, isn't it?
>>male voice in audience: Yeah, I've never
done on it. I've always been afraid. I have
no idea where the buses go or, or you know
what the bus people would be like.
>>Jeff Garlin: That's exactly right. You could
be actually taken to another land.
[laughter]
Alright –
>>male voice in audience: Yeah.
>>Jeff Garlin: I'm going back to reading.
A pleasure all of you. If you other two had
gotten there earlier you get free tickets
to my show.
[laughter]
But I'm afraid that's not going to happen
for ya.
[laughter]
>>male voice in audience: Too bad.
>>Jeff Garlin: Sorry. But please come. Twenty
dollars only, that's it. You know; but sorry
no free ones.
[laughter]
Alright here we go.
But I hope you enjoyed the car, I hope the
caterer was worth it.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Okay, here we go.
I'm waiting in Westwood for my second bus;
again worried about catching the right one.
Two buses show up and whoosh fifty people
get on, same as this morning. Behind them
my bus Santa Monica 3 pulls up. Santa Monica
3!
[laughter]
There it is. I'm walking up to the door and
boom it pulls off. What?
People inside stare at me blankly as the driver
takes off. Bus drivers never make eye contact.
That must be the first rule of bus driving
school. If someone's running to the bus don't
make eye contact.
[laughter]
Don't let them know you see them.
Ten to 15 more minutes go by and a couple
of buses pull up at the same time. I watch
as a girl gets off the second bus and runs
to catch the first one. But the driver closes
the door on her and takes off.
Then my bus comes around and it doesn't even
hesitate long enough to stop. This girl is
furious. I'm furious. We're both furious together.
The bus driver who originally dropped her
off saw the whole thing and actually yells
out, "You should report it."
I take out my space pen and a notepad and
write down the number to call with complaints.
My first bus day and I'm making complaints.
[laughter]
After another five minutes the girl gets her
bus, but ten minutes pass and mines still
not coming. I'm tempted to, to call a producer
of Curb and have them send a van to pick me
up. But I think, "No." No matter how late
I get there, I have to stick with my mission.
I decided to walk down to the corner, there's
another bus stop there. I look up at the sign
and see my bus number. I wasn't standing at
the right stop. I laugh.
Finally I get on the bus to Brentwood and
I realize that my whole commute today, commute
today; a commute that would normally take
me with traffic maybe 40 minutes takes me
two and a half hours.
The bus drops me off about a half mile away
from the set and one of the transportation
guys at Curb Your Enthusiasm sees me walking
and is clearly confused. "I left a space open
for you. You don't have to park over there."
He's referring to my usual parking space by
my trailer thinking that I'm walking from
where I've parked my car. "No I took the bus."
"Oh," he says not sure what to make of this
information. He considers me for a moment
and then add, adds helpfully, "I took a train
once."
[laughter]
When I finally get to the set everybody is
so impressed. They really feel like I've accomplished
somethin'. Some people travel that far by
bus everyday for work. I'm so lucky to have
a car.
And I have to say Larry David just kept on
saying to me: "You really took the bus. No
you really took it."
[laughter]
"Wow you're a better man than I, wow."
So, what I'd like to do now is, is answer
any questions that you have or you my Santa
Monica friends.
Actually the two early ones not the late ones.
But no whatever it doesn't matter.
But Jessie are you starting things off?
>>Jessie: Yeah I'll start things off. Please,
again make sure to use the mic.
>>Jeff Garlin: Doesn't the first person get
a t-shirts? Are you cheating?
>>Jessie: I, I, I, I made sure I said anybody
who wants it. So although it's a very fine
t-shirt nothing wrong with t-shirt, I'll of
course give it up to the person who wants
it.
In Santa Monica you guys can just Ping me
as you have questions and I'll make sure that,
to stop the SFQ.
So, yeah, I will start it off by just saying
you mentioned that this book especially starts
off as a book of failures and I think I've
heard you say somewhere that it was very distinct
from someone who's teaching how to go on a
diet, who looks like they're, they're already
done with it -
>>Jeff Garlin: Right.
>>Jessie: and I wonder what kind of response
you've gotten from people about talking about
so many failures [unintelligible]?
>>Jeff Garlin: [unintelligible] Okay, few
thoughts. I would never write a how to book.
Even about comedy. I mean I know what works
for me and, and certain comedians that I,
I work with and I work with Dennis Leary and
Jon Stewart developing their HBO specials,
and write and produce stuff. And so in that
area which is my expertise I can work professionally,
but I'd never write a book about it.
I would never write a book about how I lost
weight and so can you. You know I just I'm
going green here's how you can. I just don't
like that.
However, what's really funny is on Amazon.com
I've been stupid enough to read my reviews;
the first ten reviews. And some very nice
reviews, but there's some really angry reviews,
because it's not a good enough how to book.
You know? He doesn't explain what diet.
It just was like that's not what the book
is, but yet I get penalized and my numbers
go down. But nonetheless, I am not on a diet.
I am not Mr. Green either. I am conscious
of being green.
And I am, I've changed the way I eat completely.
I haven't had sugar in over a year. I haven't
had fast food in over a year. And I'm really
comfortable with saying I will never have
sugar again.
I have bananas and oranges and what have you.
But I'm talking about sweets. No sugar for
me; done. And I'm good with that. I'm totally
comfortable with that.
And so there is no goal. My goal is only to
be healthy, and happy, and functioning in
the world. And as long as my clothes keep
getting bigger on me, and I'm exercising and
eating the way I want, I don't need to know
how much I weigh. I don't need to know any
of it. I'm just a,just changed that's all.
I do Pilates. Figure that out.
[laughter]
Which is, I hate it with a passion but it's
the greatest thing ever. It, it's, you get
the most results with Pilates. It's pretty
amazing.
So the response though people who get the
book are digging it you know, but there's
always stupid people.
[laughter]
But you know what the thing that blows my
mind though is these negative reviews on Amazon,
vitriol? Is that the right word? Crazy. Like,
like they hate me.
[laughter]
Like they couldn't wait for me to release
a book to write this review.
One person I even went to their other reviews.
They only wrote the review of my book and
their name is not Jeff Garlin. That's somebody
who hates me.
[laughter]
Wow.
Alright but I'm, but I'm good with it and
I'm going to stop reading reviews.
But people who have read the book, that I,
approached me and said nice things. I hope
you dig it.
So, alright next question. Who wants a t-shirt?
Oh here we go. Look at that my friend.
>>male voice in audience: Hey, Jeff thanks
very much for coming. I look forward to -
>>Jeff Garlin: My pleasure.
>>male voice in audience: [unintelligible]
on the shirt.
>>Jeff Garlin: And is it a Google T-shirt?
>>female voice in audience: It's right there.
[various voices speaking at once]
>>male voice in audience: To your right.
>>male voice in audience: To your right, right.
>>Jeff Garlin: Oh, hanging here. I didn't
know they made these.
[laughter]
Can you imagine me walking down the street
wearing this?
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: Hi, how are you?
Hello. So here, come, come, so here give this
to him. Hand that to him. See it's not going
to be weird you wearing it. But wow, that'd
be weird.
Like every year they give us Curb Your Enthusiasm
stuff. Like jackets and shirts and stuff.
I'm not gonna walk around with a big Curb
Your Enthusiasm. I'd feel like the biggest
douche on earth.
Okay, ask your question.
[laughter]
What's your question man?
>>male voice in audience: I just wanted hear
how it was taking these steps to be more green
and better eating habits with comedians like
Larry David and Jerry Seinfeld around you
all the time?
>>Jeff Garlin: [unintelligible] I have a,
everybody was very supportive; I, I refer
to, how did I refer to Jerry in the book?
He's, what do I call him Allison?
>>Allison: Sadistic.
>>Jeff Garlin: Sadistic, yes. That's my assistant
Allison. I refer to him as sadistic.
He, Jerry wants me to lose weight but he took
the approach that most comedians would take
and he would say things to me like: "Hey Garland
if you could have anything you want for dinner
tonight what would it be?"
And I'd say "Cheeseburger and chocolate milk,
chocolate milkshake."
He'd go, "That's what I'm getting."
[laugter]
And he would I'd be at dinner with him. And
he's day "I told you I was ordering this."
You know. But he's a great guy and he's, and
Larry David by the way eats very healthy and
has, besides maybe my mom and my wife he wants
me to lose weight more than anyone. He's really
into it so; very supportive. Everyone around
me is very supportive.
And then for me the hardest part was withdrawal
from sugar. Took like, it was like three weeks
of hell, it really was. I might as well have
been doing heroin, coming down because - probably
heroin would be easier you know? Cause they
don't add heroin to foods.
[laughter]
So I wouldn't be having it, I wouldn't be
looking at how many grams of heroin are in
my Raisin Bran.
>>unidentified voice in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Jeff Garlin: Yeah, so that was difficult
'cause I didn't sleep for like two three days
at a time, numerous times. Had horrible headaches,
nauseous, weak, tired. It was hard, yeah.
And feelings came up that I wasn't so fond
of.
[laughter]
Alright. So next up. See, I love that you
guys are doing it. That's so funny and you're
havin' fun. Please ask me questions.
>>male voice in audience: We're plants.
>>Jeff Garlin: Anything you can't be stupid.
Think of Ralph Waldo Emerson, Self-Reliance.
Come on.
>>male voice in audience: On, on that note
Ralph Waldo Emerson on the book cover and
those two don't have the book or those on
YouTube. On the back you are leaning against
a tree looking a bit winded and there seems
to be a either small marmot or groundhog that
is wearing headphones plugged into a tree
listening to Enya.
>>Jeff Garlin: Yes
>>male voice in audience: And I was just wondering
if you could explain the significance.
>>Jeff Garlin: Don't want to.
>>male voice in audience: Okay.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: I wanna keep it a mystery and
let people guess as to what's going on. There's
a video on my website that actually has the
character in it that will explain it further
@ jeffgarlin.com. And it's there, it's there.
Yeah. And, yeah.
What is the clicking I'm hearing? What are
you, what's go, alright I was confused, okay.
[laughter]
Here at Google, by the way you, for those
of you on YouTube, here at Google it's not
so organized.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: It's not. Oh, I've been waiting
for you. Come on up.
>>female voice in audience: Well I'm only
half way through your book but I noticed -
>>Jeff Garlin: You're halfway through my book?
>>female voice in audience: Yeah.
>>Jeff Garlin: Did you start today?
>>female voice in audience: No.
>>Jeff Garlin: That's wild. Go ahead, okay
go ahead.
>>female voice in audience: I noticed, I,
I just read the part where you went to your
friend's house who showed you how green he
was.
>>Jeff Garlin: Vaguely
>>female voice in audience: Yeah, and you
were complaining that your wife probably wouldn't
let you do that.
>>Jeff Garlin: Yes.
>>female voice in audience: I wanted to know
maybe how that, how it ends or how -
>>Jeff Garlin: My wife never lets me do any,
well actually all through the book are fights
with my wife. Some of which I recorded and
transcribed.
[laughter]
Because she's not against being green, but
she's against the inconvenience of it and
the aesthetics of it.
Sometimes green is not so atheistic and it
is always inconvenient. Always inconvenient.
Really I've chosen to live now by paying attention
to what I eat and exercising and being green;
I've chosen an inconvenient life. My life
is not remotely convenient anymore. Yeah,
there's nothing convenient about it.
[laughter]
So -
>>female voice in audience: Okay.
>>Jeff Garlin: So, it's all through the book
we fight and I, I don't wanna spoil the ending,
but yeah she wins always. I'm married that's
what, how it works. I wanna stay married.
It's not about winning and losing it's about
she winning.
[laughter]
She's winning.
Ok, anyone else?
[pause]
I want you guys to wrestle.
[laughter]
No.
>>male voice in audience: Well, I got here
first so.
>>Jeff Garlin: Yes.
>>male voice in audience: I was interested
you know why going green and losing weight
specifically? Were there life changing events
that like brought them to your attention?
Why not saving the whales or something like
that?
>>Jeff Garlin: Well, the answer. Why not saving
the whales? I've had no contact, I'm pro,
I love whales and -
>>male voice in audience: Me too.
>>Jeff Garlin: I'm happy they shut down that
sushi restaurant that was serv, serving whale
meat. Love sushi; don't want the whale meat.
[laughter]
So, a couple things: first off, just know
that in my past, I talk about this in the
book, I have Type II diabetes. I had a stroke
in 2000. After I had diabetes and the stroke
I ballooned up to 320, which is not what you're
supposed to do after you have life changing
things.
But it was the movie Wall-E that sort of,
'cause I've been asked to write books before.
Do I have any ideas and I'm like, "I don't
wanna just write a book of nothing, I want
it to be about something."
And I came out of the last time I saw it,
it was at the El Capitan Theater in Hollywood,
and it was literally the last screening before
it closed. I was in the late show.
And I remember being out on the street with
my wife and I'm like: "I have the idea for
a book! I have an idea for a book!" And she
said: "What?"
I said: "I'll be like the captain who has
to get his health under control, and go green
'cause their coming back to earth and it's
not so green. And I'll be like him and I'll
write about it. And I'll call it my footprint."
I had the title right from the get go.
I thought it would happen much quicker, but
as I started writing the book I began to gain
weight from the stress of producing a TV show,
being a father, a husband, where I had script
deadline for something and - so all the stress,
I began - and then when I read, read what
I was writing about, I realized, "Oh I'm screwy.
I got to fix this." And that's what changed
everything in me, reading it.
>>male voice in audience: Thank you very much.
>>Jeff Garlin: Thank you.
[pause]
>>male voice in audience: Hey Jeff, thanks
for comin'.
>>Jeff Garlin: Hey, my pleasure, my friend.
>male voice in audience: I wanted your take
on public transit and why cities I guess in
particular L.A. is so bad, I mean everyone,
I've never lived there but everyone complains
about the traffic -
>>Jeff Garlin: Yeah the traffic's terrible
and public transportation.
>>male voice in audience: So what are the,
yeah so what are the -
>>Jeff Garlin: I almost feel that the public
transportation in L.A. is random. Meaning
like, yes put a bus line over there, sure.
There's never any thought to we should build
one down Olympic downtown or, it's just seems
like no, is just seems like whenever there's
probably a new mayor or something somebody
new gets there, "Yeah, let's do that." It
just seems random.
And, and it's kind of expensive to ride. I
was shocked at how much the monthly pass cost,
you know? It was all I don't know. I don't
wanna,
I've committed, by the way, when I am home
in L.A. and I go to my office one day a week
I'm still gonna to take the bus.
Cause I figure that that's like a cool thing
that maybe if people hear about that they'll
want to do the same thing. One day I won't
take a car. And maybe they should make everybody,
no they shouldn't do that. I, I don't want
anyone being made to do anything, but to really
answer your question, I don't have a clue.
[laughter]
And I've asked Ed Bagley about it who takes
the bus quite often. He doesn't have a clue
either. So it's not like I'm an expert and
I know anything.
>>male voice in audience: So I guess with
all of the star power and the causes that
folks have and the eco-consciousness of seemingly
a lot of celebrities -
>>Jeff Garlin: Yes
>>male voice in audience: you don't see many
people standing out for the cause of improved
public transportation?
>>Jeff Garlin: Alright, can you see Paris
Hilton, Tom Hanks waiting for a bus?
[laughter]
Seriously, can you?
>>male voice in audience: No.
>>Jeff Garlin: And they're so famous. See
when I rode the bus nobody recognized me,
I have a good level of fame. Which is, if
you know who I am your very pleased and excited,
and then if you don't I'm just a guy.
[laughter]
It's not like you saw me on Hollywood Squares
or something, you know?
[laughter]
I'm famous for some level of accomplishment
as opposed to fame for fame's sake.
And so you're not gonna to get, I, I just
don't think there, there are a lot of celebrities,
smaller than me sure who should but you know.
That's, yeah, I don't think it's gonna to
work. It's too bad.
Alright but you know, hey I take the train
in New York. And it's so funny I'll be on
the train and people will go: "What are you
doin' here?" As if I got a limo following
me above ground wherever I go. I could be
on the limo but I've chosen you know?
[laughter]
Yeah, yeah, I, I wish it was better, but I
don't have the answer.
I'll answer questions about Curb. I'll answer
questions about anything. I don't care, Old
West Collectibles.
[pause]
>>male voice in audience: No, please take
the mic.
>>female voice in audience: Sorry.
>>Jeff Garlin: Did you really offer to let
him go first?
>>female voice in audience: I did.
>>Jeff Garlin: OK.
[laughter]
Do you know that yesterday I spoke, over here
at San Francisco at a bookstore and a woman
in the audience told a story, after I talked
about the bus, she goes, "I wanna tell you
this story." And she told me a story about
robbing a seven-year old to get a bus fare.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Garlin: I don't, whatever. I just felt
rather strange in why she shared that. So
please don't share something like that.
[laughter]
Hi, go ahead.
>>female voice in audience: Talking about
bookstores, when you look for your book at
a bookstore –
>>Jeff Garlin: Um-hum.
>>female voice audience: it's in the comedy
section?
>>Jeff Garlin: I know it's in the comedy section,
it's, it's in different sections. It's, unless
it's on the front table it's - here's the
thing it's not a best seller. Some stores,
when the person who decides likes me, when
someone likes me put it out in the front.
Or there's a lot of 'em you know in different
sections. And then other stores when they
don't know who I am, which is more people
than not, they're like, "Oh comedy." So there's
no what can you do?
>>female voice in audience: So yeah that was
basically my question. Where would you, where
would you ideally place your book –
>>Jeff Garlin: Where would I place my book?
>>female voice in audience: in a bookstore?
[pause]
>>Jeff Garlin: Oh, boy. I'd probably place
it right next to wherever what's her name,
who ran for vice-president?
>>several voice in unison: Sarah Palin.
>>Jeff Garlin: Yeah, right next to Sarah Palin's
book because or Mitt Romney's book because
people are buying those; so just right next
to theirs.
[laughter]
That's where I'd like it. I don't care a particular
section.
By the way, can I also say, and I'm saying
this on YouTube; if Sarah Palin runs for President
I am vowing to run for President.
[laughter]
[applause]
>>Jeff Garlin: Here's why: I don't want to
win, know that. But you need somebody at the
debates that when she's done talking –
[laughter]
and she's says one of her things than I can
look over and go, "What the fuck are you talking
about?"
[laughter]
And I won't care when I'm kicked out of the
debate. I will, I will have said my piece;
we all would have had a good chuckle.
[laughter]
So I want to say that.
Alright, so yes.
>>male voice in audience: I'm about half way
through the book too, but I, I was pretty
surprised that you, I think it was at 36 you
said you had the stroke?
>>Jeff Garlin: I had the stroke at 36, 37
yeah, around there.
>>male voice in audience: Yeah, and can you
just talk a little bit about, I guess, how
you got through that time because I remember
when you said something about your mother-in-law
walkin' around the house and sort of looking
at you a little suspiciously. Did she -
>>Jeff Garlin: Well, I mean, let me, let me.
Okay. So I, I had a stroke in 2000, February
of 2000.
And prior to the stroke I'd gotten in a car,
I got rear-ended in a car accident. I had
whiplash, which is extremely painful. And
while I had whiplash and I couldn't sleep
and I was crying a lot cause the pain was
so intense, my mother-in-law was staying with
us.
And at that point she still didn't know what
to make of me, you know. And so when you're
in great stress and pain you don't want someone
looking at you with everything you do.
[laughter]
I thought and my wife who was pregnant with
our second child, I was like sort of, my eye
was drooping; and the, it was just a bad situation.
And then one morning I woke up and had a stroke
which was a joy for everyone.
Yeah, I don't know what got me through it;
persaverance. I talk about it in the book,
the end of the book. I talk about it early
in the book and I talk about it at the end
of the book, how I sort of recovered from
that and it's really the ending of the book
so I don't wanna give it away 'cause it's
a, a very personal thing, so. I mean personal
that I'd share, but not, you know what I mean.
Okay.
So, Jessie what are you doing?
>>Jessie: So unfortunately we only have, you
know something bad is about to happen. No,
we only have time for one more question. Our
friends in Santa Monica would like to ask
it, but
>>Jeff Garlin: Oh, okay.
>>Jessie: just make sure we leave time for
signings, personal questions, and -
>>Jeff Garlin: Okay, sure.
>>Jessie: [unintelligible]
>>Jeff Garlin: Okay, so who's asking in Santa
Monica?
>>Julie: Julie is.
>>Jeff Garlin: Oh Julie. I love you, Julie.
[laughter]
>>Julie: I figured since we began together
we should end together.
>>Jeff Garlin: I think that's the way to do
it, Julie. Julie who really shows what it's
like to appreciate me.
[laughter]
Everyone in the country who's watching us
right now, could learn a lot from Julie.
[laughter]
Thank you, Julie my number one fan. Go sister,
go.
[laughter]
>>Julie: Okay, my question is about Curb.
'Cause I noticed when you guys did the panel
discussion last week you were all cracking
each other up a lot.
So I'm wondering like how many takes do you
have to do of a scene on average since so
much of it is improve, and I imagine you're
making each other laugh? Is it hard not to
break character or do you have like a method
way of acting that gets you through it?
>>Jeff Garlin: Well, for me I don't break
character 'cause I'm a professional.
[laughter]
And so I'm not sort of sittin' back and enjoying
going, "This is great." I'm focused on my
work.
I have laughed one time where I could not
control myself; one time in all the years.
And that was this past season when Larry dropped
his pants and he was wearing the red panties.
[laughter]
I knew it was coming, I knew it was coming
but I wasn't prepared for it. And so when
he dropped his pants and he's wearing little
red panties, I fell over and it took like
ten minutes for me to recover.
[laughter]
That's was very, it was unsettling and hysterical
at the same time. So yeah, one time I did.
We do laugh, but Larry laughs the most. If
he finds something funny sometimes it's hard
to, to pull him back. 'Cause he just likes
laughin'. But we all laugh all day. I've got
a great job; it's like Google.
[laughter]
>>male voice in audience: So funny
>>Jeff Garlin: I'll see you Friday.
>>Julie: I'll be there.
>>Jeff Garlin: You will cool. Alright. So
I'm goin' be, I'm sorry you can't participate
in the next part. But there be books there
on Friday.
But I am, I'm going to sign and hang out and
talk to whoever wants to talk to me.
>>male voice in audience: Well, thanks again,
Jeff Garlin.
>>Jeff Garlin: Alright, thank you. Thank you
very much.
[applause]